[Music]
in 1820 french astronomer alexis bouvard
noticed something strange
the gravity of the inner planets
couldn't account for the orbital
movement of the outermost planet
uranus his hypothesis
there must be a massive object
influencing it
that eventually led mathematicians to
correctly calculate the location of our
eighth planet
neptune and this discovery fueled a mad
hunt to discover more planets using this
method
to give it an approximation everybody
and their brother
have looked for planets beyond neptune i
mean the moment
neptune was discovered everyone wanted
to do it because
it was this clear demonstration that you
can use math to discover
objects unfortunately
since then no major planet in our solar
system has been found
but thanks to modern telescopes
thousands of smaller objects have been
discovered in the past few decades
beyond neptune called trans-neptunian
objects or tnos
like sedna one nicknamed the goblin
and another nicknamed biden and
planetary
scientists at the california institute
of technology
have noticed some anomalies with these
objects
the first is the fact that the orbits
all lie in the same plane the second
is that they all swing out into the same
direction
now the third is where it gets
interesting a large fraction of these
orbits that swing out
and to look like they've been arranged
are
detached from the orbit of neptune their
hypothesis
a giant theoretical planet beyond
neptune which accounts for the anomalies
of these objects
planet nine and thanks to a new
telescope
equipped with the largest digital camera
ever
built we may be one sky survey away from
finally finding it
it will be a game changer because it's
big
and it can detect very faint objects we
will
find objects all the way from near-earth
asteroids out to trans-neptunian objects
and beyond
after the discovery of neptune
scientists thought there had to be yet
another planet to account for the
remaining orbital anomalies of uranus
they called it planet x there were
hundreds of attempts by scientists to
find this missing planet over the next
few decades
but as it turns out they were wrong
astronomers had incorrectly estimated
neptune's mass
later confirmed by voyager in 1989 which
did account for these remaining
anomalies the reason pluto was initially
considered a planet is because it was an
object that was sort of in the right
part of the sky where
clyde tombows looking for planet x a
predicted object that was supposed to
resolve
remaining orbital anomalies of uranus
although pluto would later be classified
as a dwarf planet
since it was too small and too far away
to have any influence on the outer
planets
this was the start of a new era for
discoveries of bodies in the outer solar
system
pluto is one of what's thought to be
hundreds of thousands of tnos
and the more that are discovered the
more data seems to point to a ninth
planet
[Music]
we see this grouping of trajectories all
these
little pieces of debris that are hanging
out in this population
of icy planetesimals beyond neptune all
of their orbits
tend to be aligned in a very specific
way
that is difficult to ascribe to chance
or to describe in any
other way other than the existence of
yet another
planetary mass body hanging out in the
distant solar system
[Music]
the aligned orbits hinted a large body
pulling them in the same direction
they also found each tno to be tilted on
its axis in approximately the same way
and they don't appear to be put there by
neptune
these orbits should all hug the orbit of
neptune
and many of them don't why not
well the here in planet nine once again
comes in back into the fold
you need planet nine's gravity as it
turns out to kind of
untether these objects from the orbit of
neptune
there's other circumstantial evidence as
well if you compare the sizes of
discovered exoplanets
planets outside our solar system the
majority fall into categories known as
super earths
or many neptunes on average
each star if you look up in the night
sky has at least
one planet and most planets
that inhabit this galaxy if you will
are super earths these objects that are
a few
earth masses it's actually quite
remarkable that the solar system
as efficient as it was at creating
planets
appears to be missing these short period
super earth type objects which are very
common elsewhere
so if planet 9 does exist and is super
earth size
it would make our solar system similar
to the majority we've observed
to make all these calculations and
determine the potential orbit of planet
nine
the team at caltech put collected data
into computer simulations
as far as the math allows us to
calculate uh
it's about five earth masses okay so it
falls
in between an earth-type planet and
an ice giant such as uranus or neptune
they also estimate that it's on a 20 000
year orbit around the sun
that's ten times further away than
neptune is from the sun
we can calculate the orbit and the mass
of planet nine
to a pretty good approximation what we
cannot do
is tell you where it is on the night sky
fundamentally it's all just gravity it's
a different
type of dynamics okay which allows us to
infer the existence of planet nine than
was the case
with neptune with neptune you could say
it's right there
and get the orbit kind of wrong here
you have information about the orbit not
so much the information of where it is
on the night sky so that's why we're
stuck
uh kind of observing a whole swath of
the sky which takes a long time isn't it
indeed difficult to do that massive
swath of sky
makes finding such a faint faraway
object like finding a needle in a
haystack
planet nine is millions of times less
bright on the night sky
than neptune that's
really really dim i mean if you really
think about it neptune is not something
you can
observe with your naked eye you need a
telescope to see
and planet nine is millions of times
less bright
critics say that the team at caltech
have an observational bias
having not looked in enough quadrants of
the sky at different times of year to
conclude that there is in fact orbital
clustering
essentially more data is needed
the good news is we are kind of entering
the next generation
of such surveys now with the
commissioning and the construction of
the vera rubin telescope in chile
so i think that's going to be a game
changer in this
in this problem the vera rubin
observatory is a new telescope
that will be coming online in the next
couple of years to complete the widest
most detailed survey of the sky ever
conducted
this legacy survey of space and time or
lsst
may finally tell us once and for all if
planet nine is out there
ribbon observatory is a next generation
survey telescope
that is set to observe the entire night
sky
every few nights repeatedly for 10 years
the idea being we can build up not only
a deep image of the sky
but also a multi-color movie
unlike telescopes like the hubble space
telescope
the reuben observatory's field of view
is extremely
wide and thanks to its giant 3 gigapixel
camera
which is the size of a small car it can
also detect incredibly
faint objects lurking in the outer
regions of the solar system
so then narrow field of view telescopes
like hubble can take a closer look
because it's a survey telescope we have
a plan to go
and do this survey across the night sky
but then
also process all the images and reduce
those to catalogs
so that astronomers can come along and
then they can look at the catalogs and
they can do
searches for unusual objects or things
that match what they're looking for
just using the catalogs that we're
producing
that'll help scientists solve the
mysteries of dark matter
dark energy map the milky way and
inventory moving objects throughout the
solar system like tnos
so for example in the solar system
almost every population of objects that
you can think of in the solar system
we will detect about 10 to 100 times
more of
we will take 2 million images
over 10 years which is actually 4
million
actual pictures of the night sky so each
image
is 3.2 gigapixels and we take about
1600 images per night that's about 20
terabytes of data per night
to find objects within our solar system
the telescope will take
two images of every patch of sky
separated by an hour
and from the motion of the points of
light over that hour they'll be able to
distinguish between faint stars
and objects within our own solar system
that's a problem for planet nine though
objects that are far beyond neptune will
be difficult to detect from the motion
of only an hour
another problem is planet 9 may be in
the northern hemisphere sky
due to the frequent clear skies and low
light pollution
reuben observatory is strategically
located below the equator in chile
and will mostly see southern hemisphere
skies
but if it is there reuben observatory is
equipped to find it have colleagues who
believe in planet nine and i have
colleagues who don't believe in planet
nine
it's really hard to say definitively
that it's out there
we have to go and look so one of the
things that lsst
can do is actually contribute by
surveying
more of this guy so people are already
looking for planet nine
but given the fact that you have to look
at a large amount of sky
and you need to look for very faint kind
of objects
that's kind of can be a slow process so
lsst will be able to do that much more
quickly so within the first year
of of surveying the sky lsst
could see if there was a planet nine
within its survey footprint
down to the magnitudes that we can see
the other thing though that we can do is
provide further constraints on
what the orbit could be because a lot of
the constraints so far come from these
also relatively rare very distant
objects
and we'll find a lot more of those too
we'll also be able to tell if it really
is just a bias
in the observing data
even if the planet isn't found it may
give astronomers more data to find it
during future surveys
or it may show that there are other
explanations for the orbits and tilts of
these tnos
as some scientists have argued
either way a hunt to find planet nine
will undoubtedly lead to the location of
new
undiscovered tnos and whatever else is
in our neighborhood
from the perspective of daily life no
one's gonna
change their daily habits you know start
brushing their teeth more or whatever
you know because there's a planet
hundreds of times this as far away from
the sun as is the earth
but at the same time look i mean it is
part of
human nature to explore right it is it
is part of human nature to ask the
question
what's out there what lies beyond the
ocean what lies beyond
this hill what lies beyond this planet
war
lies beyond the edge of the solar system
um
there's something deeply satisfying
about asking and answering these
questions
that i think is is really important to
kind of our collective
human experience
you